all right so it takes a lot to piss me
off on a beautiful sunny day in Los
Angeles but something is actually
driving me legitimately crazy at the
moment and it's pissing off amma - there
has been a drone flying over my house I
kid you not
a drone real drone flying over my house
- last like three or four weeks every
couple days usually around six seven
o'clock at night just floating above my
house I have a little outdoor porch and
it's just right there and I don't know
that it's you know homing in on me but
it's above the area I don't know if this
guy has a camera on this thing if he's
watching what I'm doing I have friends
over having a couple of drinks on the
porch and this is a major major problem
you know we talk about drones a lot we
talk about you know we have drones in
Pakistan and we're killing innocent
people sometimes Americans but I think
the next step of the drone discussion is
drones right here in America and should
regular people have the right to own
drones and to fly them wherever they
want and invade other people's privacy
this guy could have a camera watching me
I have no idea we all have a right to
privacy right in our own homes and that
right is going to slowly be etched away
and it's just another continuation of
our rights that disappear like with the
NSA stuff and that our privacy will just
go away and it'll happen slowly so we
won't even realize it but you don't have
a right to fly something over someone's
house and watch what they're doing I
want to hear some of the presidential
candidates talk about this as far as I
know Rand Paul's the only one talking
about at the moment but I want my right
to privacy I don't want you flying a
freakin drone over my house call me
crazy but that's what I'm demand